one of our colleagues was briefly
detained as he was reporting from
eastern ukraine charles stratford is
also now in dunedin pro here's his story
we've returned from the city of zappos
where the situation is becoming
increasingly tense a lot more military
checkpoints a lot more military hardware
than than we saw there yesterday
as an indication of how tense it is we
were preparing to go live to do a live
broadcast where out of nowhere seemingly
a group of ukrainian soldiers and
ukrainian police appeared with their
guns many of them pointing towards us
firing in the air
they demanded that we get out of the
vehicle we threw ourselves to the ground
our cameraman's
telephone was kicked out of his hand and
two bullets fired from a kalashnikov
into that telephone now it's important
to recognize that these men were just
doing their jobs
there are increasing fears amongst the
ukrainian military and security services
about what they describe as saboteurs
trying to get into cities and
compromising military positions
but as i say our
cameras were still rolling when this
incident happened
let's take a look
hi uh
doha
yeah yeah yeah
stop stop stop stop stop filming
[Music]
journalists
[Music]
also reports from the port city of mary
opal witnesses telling us that what they
describe as being increasing numbers of
paramilitaries on the streets ukrainian
power ministries helping the ukrainian
army trying to defend the city from what
we understand is a push by russian
forces from the west we know that the
city has also suffered heavy shelling
from the east
we've also been speaking to people
fleeing the area north of crimea around
the city of kerason
people telling us or alleging that
russian forces that have taken control
of some of those towns are preventing
ukrainian citizens from leaving them
the situation on the roads around
denipro
very tense checkpoints a lot more strict
at one checkpoint
we saw a russian helicopter fly low over
the checkpoint causing panic causing
people to to scatter away even the
security services that that were manning
that checkpoint but there are increasing
fears of the tens if not hundreds of
thousands of civilians that are trying
to put as much distance as they can
between them
and russian forces advancing on these
ukrainian cities
as the the front lines become
increasingly blurred